[Music]
are there going to be viable
alternatives
to medicalizing mental health what we
should be wary of
is seeing these phenomena as largely
medical phenomena which require
medical intervention rather than
responses to a world which is
challenging we were throwing out the old
category
of normal that we used to think of
pathology
and normality it's the big shift from
asking what's wrong with you to asking
what's happened to you
[Music]
we shouldn't think of mental health as
either having a mental illness or not
we should think of continua between
mental health and mental illness
from the moment you wake up in the
morning to the point where you go to
sleep at night and
possibly beyond because sleep affects
your mental health you are swimming
in the causes of mental health and ill
health in terms of your relationships
with the people the social and
economic environment you live in and so
on and these are very powerful
determinants of mental health
we shouldn't think of mental health as
either having a mental illness or not
we should think of continua between
mental health and mental illness and
those social factors knock you
along or back and forth along the
continuum so
where we draw the line between health
and illness
is to some extent arbitrary although we
shouldn't that shouldn't worry it's all
that much because that's true a lot of
physical illnesses like hypertension as
well
but what we should be wary of is seeing
these phenomena as largely medical
phenomena which require medical
intervention
rather than responses to a world which
is challenging
and difficult to live in and difficult
to navigate our way through and we
should think about how we can change the
world in order to make it that we
are lower down that continuum more
towards the
the side of healthy functioning and able
to live our lives you know in a
fulfilling way
the new way of thinking our framework of
neurodiversity
is that there isn't a single way to be
normal there are many ways to be normal
so my starting point is that biology is
an important contributor to how the mind
works
and my own field is in autism
children and adults with autism and at
the moment we're studying
families that have many children with
autism
so in one family uh we've found examples
of this
you might find a mother with six
children
on the spectrum so that's telling us
that our genes are involved
it's very likely and we're going to
focus our efforts to identify genes
by looking at these really unusual
families
where something is is going on within
the family
but i don't want to want you to go away
with the idea that
biology and genetics um can explain
everything and this is
really the point of agreement with
richard i think social and cultural
factors are just as important
so i would just pick out a few examples
some of which
richard's already raised um
one one social factor i would really
single out is
social isolation there's plenty of
evidence
that if you're isolated you're more
likely to become depressed
so that's nothing to do with your with
your biology is to do with your social
networks and social support
a second example again richard mentioned
is trauma
um you know trauma is not good for your
mental health
and if you look at people who end up
with a diagnosis
of borderline personality disorder these
are individuals
mostly women who have trouble regulating
their emotions
and trusting other people if you look
back at their childhoods
some 80 percent of them have experienced
child abuse or neglect
so that's telling us that early
experience is really important for later
adult mental health
um i've now touched on the the whole
topic of early experience
and many of you know about the concept
of attachment
and secure attachment between an infant
and a parent
and decades of research are really
supporting the idea that the security of
attachment
between an infant and a parent
really predicts later mental health
so if you don't have the opportunity for
whatever reason
to fo to form a secure attachment with a
caregiver
you're less likely to be able to trust
other people and be prone
to experiences like paranoia but you're
also less likely to develop
self-esteem self-confidence um
and all the protective and resilient
factors
that are going to protect you as you go
through adversity in life
so some people think of early attachment
which is which is really a social
experience
as almost an inner pot of gold that you
carry with you
as you face challenges you can either
overcome them or become a victim of them
um the other last couple of points in
this introduction
is i want to really um highlight a
fairly new concept which is about
individual differences
and uh in my field it's called
neurodiversity
that there isn't a single way to be
normal
and effectively we're throwing out the
old category
of normal that we used to think of
pathology
and normality and i think that the new
way of thinking this this
framework of neurodiversity is that
there are many ways to be normal
and i think this kind of links to my
last point which is about respect
when we talk about people with mental
illnesses
we're effectively pathologizing them
we're saying there's something wrong
with them
and the international classification
systems that psychiatry has produced
talks about mental disorders or mental
diseases
so we're really using this medical model
which says there's something wrong with
you
if we accept that there there's a range
of experience in the population
some people may hear voices some people
may be sociable or less sociable but
this is all part of the normal range
what we start to do is respect
individual differences
we make people feel that they're not
broken or dysfunctional but just
different
and a lot about mental health is feeling
included
feeling respected and being given
dignity there's a bit of an
oversimplification about rationality the
most
psychotic person will have pockets where
they're completely rational
is there an absolute madness are there
times when it would be good to dispense
with these ideas of being released
i just want to say i'm not going to use
the word madness i hate
the word madness i think it should be
abandoned i think it's
it's a voyeuristic deeply stigmatizing
word i haven't used it to date and i'm
not going to use it
now um it cause it's it it conjures up
images of
gothic horror and of morbid fascination
so
i think we should be talking call it
psychosis
but but not not madness i think there's
a bit of an oversimplification
simplification about rationality
even the most psychotic person that i
have ever seen
will have pockets where they're
completely rational
we call it capacity in in in the jargon
somebody has capacity in certain areas
may not have it in another area
and that's what happens in psychosis in
a particular area of their life they may
not
they may have lost rationality for the
time being because with treatment
it is a temporary condition generally
but other areas i mean my patients i can
have reasonable conversations with them
about books about music about their
families about their hobbies
it's not as though they're talking
completely gibberish that's complete
misunderstanding it's just in a certain
area
of their lives what has changed
dramatically
is about people knowing that they're
unwell
[Music]
so the world i work in is bringing
together the
the biological reasons the social
reasons and the psychological reasons so
i think on that front
even though i'm medical we're very much
on a similar page but i guess it's about
why do we feel like there might be an
epidemic they do big surveys
and these big surveys fight can
can say who has an actual
diagnosis who meets the threshold for
anxiety and depression
there has been a slight increase
in anxiety and depression but it's not
huge and it's
mainly in older adolescent girls
but what has changed dramatically
the people is about people knowing that
they're unwell
so it used to be that you might meet the
criteria for anxiety and depression
but you wouldn't know it so if someone
said are you depressed
you'd go no and you wouldn't seek help
what's happening now is that people are
much more aware when they might be
hitting those thresholds
and and when they hit those thresholds
they're more likely to seek help
still the people who hit those
thresholds there's only less than
half of people with diagnosable
common mental disorders ask for help
but our mental health systems are
chronically underfunded and have been
for years and we can't meet
that growing awareness and i think that
gives people a sense of an
epidemic there's a huge hazard here from
the
health complex and this is the thing
that we need to learn to
undo when i actually did to medicine
first we had very few illnesses roughly
40 or so they're now over 800.
when you went along to a doctor you were
hoping that you get a person who was
wise and was going to
put you on the pill that treated the
illness you had if you had an
illness but you were hoping that they
had the wisdom to know when you
didn't have one now that's the
background that led me into medicine
which is that the illnesses are real
and the treatments work but one of the
reason
a bunch of people who are a
generation older than me went into the
mental health field was they had the
experience in world war ii of a bunch of
people with
serious illnesses who when they got
injured weren't really injured they
recovered
they were thrilled to bits to be injured
because this is the way out
of the war and the extreme case of this
was people who were
injured and the army had
run out of morphine and gave them saline
and the guy's pains disappeared
completely so
what you've got here is social context
and an
awful lot of doctors became aware that
the social context is extremely
important
yes yellows are real yes the treatments
work but social context
is extraordinarily important where we're
at now however is we now have 800 plus
illnesses and the pharmaceutical
industry are creating most of them
they're giving you
pre-diabetes pre-hypertension
pre-metabolic syndrome
pre-depression pre-this pre-that pre the
other
you're at risk once you're born you're
at risk and your duty is to
have these risks treated for your entire
life
back in the 60s back in the 70s you had
a pill you only had
ever one pill usually at a time and for
a brief period of time till the disease
went away now if you live in the states
and pretty soon here
from the age of three or four you will
be on a bunch of pills for your entire
life and part of the problem here is
that things have been named
by industry and you've all been duped
into thinking that you have an illness
when you don't you're at risk there's a
huge
hazard here from the health complex
and this is the thing that we need to
learn to undo
the discussion that the medical
profession needs to have is what is
medicine's contract
and that dialogue hasn't started
what david is trying to do is attempting
not to throw the baby out with the bath
water he's trying to drown the baby in
the bath water
you see the issue
there's absolutely no doubt that over
the last 30 40 years number of diagnosis
has increased
the question david should be asking is
it simply in response to pharmaceutical
companies and i would say
no i pharmacy to the companies at this
point there's not a single
pharmaceutical company in this country
which is developing any new psychiatric
drugs
so yes part of it is that they're trying
to sell the old drugs for new symptoms
and that may be what's creating some of
the problem
but also equally importantly i think the
challenge really is
that when you're ill
you want to get better you want to get
back to work you want to
continue with your relationships you
want to continue with
your employment and your housing and so
on and so forth
so you want to get there whether it's a
mixture of medication plus motivational
interviewing or psychotherapy or
whatever you wish to call it
part of the discussion that the medical
profession needs to have is what is
medicine's contract
what is it that you know society expects
from doctors
and what is it that we should be doing
in return
and that dialogue hasn't started because
it's a very
implicit contract every both sides think
that we know what the other side wants
but we haven't actually sort of sat down
with
you know policy makers or you know
representatives societies or even
patients to say well exactly what what
is it that you need
so we need to be sort of i'm quite
worried that david is making furious
notes so
you know oh absolutely dinesh okay um
you're a trouble boy okay yay
um i love trouble um
and i i think the challenge really is
about
what is it that the medical profession
is good at you know
we should be very good at politics we
should be very good at prevention
and both those roles have been taken
away from us because society
just cannot afford to you know you
constantly being bombarded you know how
to look beautiful
how to have your botox done how to you
know lose weight and the same time
mcdonald's are trying to sort of feed
you
13 000 calories in one burger so
where is that tension where is that
debate taking place as to you know
what is it that we ought to be working
towards
and you know it's never going to be life
is never going to be perfect and you
know
you're doomed to die the day you're born
and you know the question is what
happens in between and how do you live
with that and how do you sort of
function
that's the crux and whether that means
taking statins or whether that means you
know
kind of controlling your diet or going
jogging or whatever
that's an individual responsibility but
we need to communicate very clearly what
individuals can do to
keep functioning at the optimal level no
the problem isn't that we're middle
class the problem is that we segregate
medical treatment from other aspects
promising that we're middle class the
problem is that we segregate
medical treatment from other aspects and
then there's bits where the the
psychiatrist might say oh that's for
social services to deal with or that's
where we need the
educational psychologist in the case of
children but what we really need
is and i think there's actually quite a
lot of that going on in psychiatry and
pediatrics and possibly in palliative
care and less in other areas of medicine
what we really need is precisely the
kind of
the teamwork that moves away from
the thinking oh kidneys okay
go and see the renal guy i only so so i
once heard a chest physician say to me
i only work up to here everything i
don't care
what happens below now of course you'll
have lots of diseases where you'll have
respiratory involvement but also renal
or cardiac or
whatever involvement and you you need to
look you need to look at the whole
and of course that's the biggest cliche
everybody says oh we need kind of
holistic
health practice i don't think i think
that's that's nice as a slogan but i
think we really need to do is to improve
the ways in which various healthcare and
social care teams
work together and the one thing i've
seen over and over and over again
in the most painful way is how
an individual's well-being falls to the
wayside
because two million too many letters are
being sent to and fro
this clinic to that clinic from this
specialist that specialist
the schools coming in for that with
their peace in the case of of children
um and also the different kind of
paradigms of thinking about a disorder
so if i can just take a quick example
um of something i just mentioned of
fetal alcohol spectrum disorder
so we see over and over again that the
number of children who end up being
taken into care in this country
are overwhelmingly sufferers of fetal
alcohol spectrum disorder
which is a disorder acquired through
exposure to alcohol in utero where
children just
acquire permanent brain damage because
of that and what we see over and over
and over again
is people say oh foster care adoption
attachment disorders and these children
are then
packed off to have play therapy
attachment therapy
nvc ddp there's there's a host of
psychological interventions that are
meant to work with children who are
traumatized and have attachment
difficulties now the problem is that
what these children have is
parts of their brain that aren't working
properly because they're poisoned with
alcohol prior to
being born so they were born with this
brain damage it's permanent
how do you alleviate the symptoms well
the first thing you need to do to go
back to the diagnosis example
is you need to get the correct diagnosis
and not have this knee-jerk reaction
that says
attachment problems when the case the
problem here is brain damage
that causes impaired executive function
and a host of other problems
so when the when the the social services
come and say oh we need to hear is
attachment therapy
for the pediatrician to stand up and say
hang on a minute have you considered
that there might be an organic
basis for this child's symptoms
and going back to the to the treatment
to the med to the
pharmaceutical option i have seen
over and over and over again um children
with
incredibly difficult behavioral and
emotional profiles
being helped substantially through the
use of medication
and i think just to counter what david
was saying about over-prescribing i
think there's also in certain pockets in
certain areas
of medicine there's under-prescribing
there's a reluctance you say oh i
couldn't possibly drug my child i
couldn't possibly poison my child with a
b and c
sometimes if the choice is between
drugging your child
or getting your child excluded from
school socially isolated
on the path to you know prison basically
it's not a very difficult choice to make
diagnosis doesn't really suggest a way
forward but a formulation can suggest a
very personal way forward
even the very senior clinicians who put
together the list of
psychiatric disorders and illnesses
which appear in great big books called
things like dsm and icd are openly
saying
that this isn't really working that
these are not proper scientific
categories that we need to
i mean essentially tear that up and
start again there are better ways of
understanding it
and there are significant disadvantages
to
giving people a diagnostic label and
then kind of embarking
on the whole journey of i've got a
mental illness with everything that that
implies
and what are these better ways of
addressing
mental health issues from a
psychologist's point of view
we like to use a particular approach
which is called formulation which is a
little bit of a jargon word
but essentially what that means is that
it's a way of putting together someone's
story
and the way that usually happens is that
you sit down with
a psychologist or perhaps another
professional
over a period of weeks or months
sometimes longer
and the professional brings their
knowledge of evidence
and of other people they've worked with
their clinical experience
the client or service user brings of
course their knowledge of their life
and what happened and what it felt like
and what it meant to them
and how it's affected them and if you
put those two forms of evidence together
you can come up with a kind of personal
story it's like a personal best guess if
you like
so these things happened this is what it
felt like this is what it meant to you
this is how you try to survive and cope
with it all
diagnosis doesn't really suggest a way
forward
but a formulation can suggest a very
personal way forward
but make sense of your experiences and
your story
and leads to quite a personal plan about
what is likely to be helpful for you
not or it shouldn't be an expert driven
process i mean almost by definition a
diagnosis is something an expert
gives you or perhaps in psychiatry often
imposes on you because try to disagree
and you'll find that often that's not
possible
whereas a formulation is certainly meant
to be much more collaborative
you and me thinking together and of
course that gives you more choice
and more control we hope we hope it
helps you to feel that you've been
listened to that someone really gets you
that someone can see things in your
point of view we hope it gives a message
of
you know encouragement to the future
because a formulation is also about what
you can do what your strengths are what
you've succeeded in what skills you have
and so ideally a person goes forward
feeling well i'm not just a bundle of
problems
i'm feeling this way and reacting this
way for very good reasons
anybody else who've been through the
same circumstances might be feeling and
behaving exactly the same way
but i think i have a better
understanding of it and i can see how i
could move forward
that's the idea all therapies in a way
are engaged in the process of trying to
make sense out of someone's story
so formulation can be part of almost any
therapeutic approach
whether it's cbt or systemic approaches
or i suppose psychoanalytic approaches
in a way it's just a way of structuring
what is likely to be going
on at some level in any therapeutic
relationship and process
but i think there are some clear
advantages to kind of getting it out on
the table
and that's partly because you can both
really check you're on the same
track the person whose story tears can
really feel they've got
control and ownership of it you can put
things right if they don't seem to quite
fit
and you can use it as a shared map and
way forward
the core message of a formulation really
is that however
apparently unusual and extreme
and overwhelming someone's thoughts
feelings and behaviors are there is a
way of making sense of it
but i think what i would say is that
obviously if some people who are
extremely distressed
and confused and really not able to sit
down and put things into
words of course you don't kind of plunge
in if you like
of course that may be a slower and more
gentle process
but certainly i would there's a great
deal of research to show that even the
things that we call
things like schizophrenia which is not a
term i would use and
psychosis which is not a term i would
use that actually
the causal factors in those kind of
experiences
you know are very similar to the causal
processes in things that we would call
anxiety and depression
you know there may be more difficult
events they may be of a more extreme
type but essentially it's a range of
people dealing with stories
you know in a range of different ways
and the stories
can be very extreme of course but
the consequences i think are always
understandable i don't want us to defend
against our feelings of anxiety i don't
want us to suppress them
i don't want us to get rid of them i
want us to listen to them
anxiety is part of life it's the price
we pay
for being alive awake and aware in the
world
and we often i think emotionally have a
choice between depression
and anxiety depression if we go inwards
and don't go out into the world and take
risks
as soon as we go out into the world and
face the unknown and start to take risks
we will often start to feel anxiety but
one of the problems we've got with that
is we treat it like it's an unwelcome
guest we want to get rid of it because
it makes us feel really uncomfortable so
we don't want to listen
to the message that the anxiety is
bringing to us
so it goes away and sulks and then comes
back again so we can end up living our
lives
in the battle between trying to get rid
of anxiety trying to tolerate it
or just being overwhelmed by it so i'm
going to be arguing that actually we
need to change our relationship with it
and we need to listen to the messages
that it's bringing we need to listen
to the wisdom and maybe there is a point
to this anxiety
because certainly at the moment there
are things out there in the world the
origins of our anxiety
whether it's virus or climate change or
biodiversity crisis
which should make us feel anxious
because they are genuine threats
so do we want to fight them or run away
from them or do we freeze or do we lie
to ourselves about them
or do we accept that these anxieties
that have been provoked at the moment
might
make perfect sense and actually what we
should be doing is trying to listen to
them
and adjust in our relationship to them
because that way we might be able to
find
a wise relationship with our anxiety we
might be able to develop more
emotional psychological resilience which
will help us to face
the looming crisis when we're through
the current pandemic
of the climate and biodiversity crisis
and that's often what children and young
people are communicating about
when they're saying how anxious and
afraid and angry they are
that we're not listening to the science
we're not taking action on the climate
crisis
we worry about children and young
people's anxieties but
actually we also need to be thinking
about the fact that we're not taking
action to reduce the cause of those
anxieties
by taking action on climate change so
what these children and young people are
doing is they're somehow embodying our
vulnerability
they're embodying for us the
vulnerability that we might be all be
feeling at the moment
as we move into this uncertain world so
i don't want us to defend against our
feelings of anxiety i don't want us to
suppress them
i don't want us to get rid of them i
want us to listen to them
and not just allow these feelings any of
those things will just make
it worse and as i said it'll come back
our anxiety for me is a sign that we
care and that we're alive and we're
awake
and we need to pay attention to that
it's a sign of empathy
without empathy and that compassion both
for ourselves and for others
particularly with these global crises
that we're dealing with now
we would not be alive or awake or
engaged as human beings
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe
today to the institute of art and ideas
at iai tv
you